[MUSIC PLAYING]
As a developer, I
enjoy writing code,
and I love building apps that
people are excited to use.
One thing I do know is
that creating a great user
experience when building apps
can be really, really hard.
Now with constant mobile
devices and the Google Cast
set of technologies,
we've done lots
of user testing to refine
a simple experience
for your users.
If you follow our guidelines
when integrating cast
into your application, you'll
insure a great end user
experience that feels
familiar to your users.
At the core of Cast is
using existing technology
to control things.
We realized that people's
phones or their tablets
make a fantastic remote control.
They have a supercomputer
in the hands
and they know how to use it.
So we modeled Cast around
using the phone or tablet
as a remote for
your entertainment
system or your shared
living room experience.
The beauty of these is that
it's familiar to people.
People already know
how to use the phone,
so people find it easy
to use because it's
consistent and obvious.
It also makes it a
personal experience
since your users can
cast their own playlist
from their own device to their
shared entertainment system.
Your life as a
developer can be easier
and more successful by taking
advantage of our guidance.
For example, we provide guidance
on how to modify your existing
applications to enable a
familiar Cast experience,
whether it's running on a phone
or tablet, or even a laptop.
Your apps need to
deal with things
like where to place the
Cast icon, the chooser
to pick Cast devices
on the network,
the states of the
icons, and so on.
We have clear guidance as part
of our documentation and design
checklist here.
Developers also need to take
care of the receiver, which
runs on the Cast device
connected to your TV or audio
system.
The UI guidance
for that helps you
enable a personal streamlined
experience with ease.
Across the whole
connected Cast experience,
the UX guidance
provides consistency
and keeps the user in control.
Like for example, you use you
could be looking at the phone
or at the TV, but
you don't know which.
So our UX guidelines make sure
that wherever your user is
looking, they see proper
information that guides them
in what they're supposed to do.
This gives them a consistent UI
and makes things really simple.
Also, when you're
in a living room,
it's like the 10
foot experience.
The screen is over there.
It's 10 feet away,
and you're over here
with the remote control.
So it's really important that
your user has full control,
because that's a really
powerful device, whether it's
connected to an 80 inch TV
or a 2000 watt sound system.
Cast is also shared experience.
Since multiple people
can be interacting
with the Cast device
us at the same time,
we designed this so that
anyone can add to the queue,
share a playlist, join
the game from their phone,
or control anything
that's playing.
For a more detailed look
at our UX guidelines,
watch our short videos
on icon placement,
controlling volume, and
dealing with connections,
or follow these links
to our UX documentation.
The best practices are
important and we really
thought them through.
It makes your life
easier and your app
will do better if you just
follow these guidelines.
[MUSIC PLAYING]